how important is this kind of first
decision for you here with you bet your
ass is important okay I don't want to be
having revolving door coaches here I
want to try to make the best decision I
can be and make it you know the best
decision possible and you know hopefully
we can have somebody here for a long
while you know that's what folks who
have ties to the Steelers organization
always saying he was a minority owner of
the Steelers a Pittsburgh guy he ideally
would like to hire a coach and have that
coach be there for a long time so our
draft today the candidates we'd hire or
at least considered to be hired for the
Carolina Panthers head coaching job it's
a three-man weave it's a three round
draft and Chris Sims has the trivia
question for Peter King and I already
object because the way this should go is
if Peters wrong I should get the first
pick but apparently I won't Chris go
ahead ask the question well it's your
show and stats like my class that's
doesn't have a microphone so if you want
the first pick and Peter gets this wrong
go ahead the hell with stats all right
here we go
the Panthers fired to time coach of the
year Ron Rivera as you guys know there
are only two other active head coaches
that have won multiple coach of the Year
awards one is Bill Belichick we know
that mr. Peter King who is the other one
I know this and when it's a good one
Peter just think he hasn't won a Super
Bowl he's got a good personality I know
there's some times he turns a lot red on
the side of the house what are we tired
how many inches you're gonna give him
you never gave me a damn hint Simms he
likes come on give me one more head
sometimes he likes to fill is his drink
with liquor after games and he talks
about it his name is Bruce Arians
[Music]
[Applause]
why did you say he's the buccaneers head
coach to Jesus let it go let it go buddy
Oh Floria your third too bad I don't
even want the first pig but my first
pick is I'm going to take the guy who I
believe is going to show David Tepper
that he's the most prepared and that's
that's Josh McDaniels Oh Peters what
damn you I was gonna be my pick oh look
I believe the shouldn't get a you
shouldn't give him so many damn hints
dummy go ahead sorry yeah I I just
believe if there is going to be a time
you know and McDaniels some years is has
sort of wanted to go I think and some
years has wanted to stay look there's
gonna be so much flux at the end of this
year that who knows I think McDaniels
would be a good guy I think he learned a
lot from the failed time in Denver a
decade ago but there's one interesting
thing I've always thought that Josh
McDaniels would only go to a place that
had a quarterback and so would he go to
a place where they're gonna start at
Ground Zero from quarterback I don't
know but I'll take median heels number
one yeah that's a good pick that would
be my number one you know again I was
there in Denver with Josh there was a
lot of things that went wrong that were
not fair to him and I'm we don't have
enough time to get into that but that
would be my number one pick I'm with you
all the way all right number two you
know I guess I'm gonna go with Robert
Salah here
from the San Francisco 49ers the
defensive coordinator I mean if you're
looking to re-energize your your team
your town a little bit he's got a great
fire and way about him of course they're
the number one defense in football in a
lot of categories I know that the the
Patriots have them beaten points per
game but the 49ers are right there to be
had you know he of course he's been he
knows what a good offense looks like you
know and I know everybody wants the
offensive guy I get that but he's been
around it got like Kyle Shanahan who I
think has taught him a lot of offense so
he's gonna understand what he wants
within an offense and bike as you've
heard me say a million times
Peter you heard me say it once today
Robert Salah does game plan specific
things he runs that Seattle defensive
scheme but he adds his own wrinkles to
it as far as blitzes and things he does
on a weekly basis and I think that would
be my next pick right there hey your
buddy Kyle Shanahan is gonna be upset
with you if you end up talking his job I
did I actually before the pick I was
like man Kyle might not like that I'm
doing this but that's what I got to do
sorry I gotta go with Greg Roman you
know it's funny how over the past week
or two he has instantly become one of
the hot names but you look at what he
did with the 49ers offense when Colin
Kaepernick was there what he's doing
with the Ravens offense and yes you have
to have the pieces to make it happen but
man he could do some interesting things
with Cam Newton if they decided to keep
him around for another year and I think
that Greg Roman is very good at
designing an offense to get the most out
of the pieces that he has and you know
the danger with hiring a defensive coach
who goes out and gets a good offensive
coordinator if that guy's good he's
gonna be gone yeah right the offensive
coordinator is far more likely to get
hired away than the defensive
coordinator so get an offensive coach
hire a defensive coordinator you think
can get it done and take it from there
so I'd go with Greg Roman is my first
pick now the thing that I want to ask
there then it's like that's the where
the Cam Newton discussion becomes
interesting right because you would
think Greg Roman wants a guy like Cam
Newton so he can run his offense and all
these cool run design things so I just I
just think that says Cam Newton and
Christian McCaffrey can you imagine what
Greg Roman could do with those two by
your up round two I'm gonna take Mike
McCarthy with the first pick of the
second round and I'll tell you why I
think David Tepper is going to you know
he certainly is gonna sit in on these
interviews and is gonna be very
proactive in this process I think he's
gonna be blown away when he meets Mike
McCarthy because Mike McCarthy this fall
has been basically having a boot camp of
trying to learn and study every other
team in the NFL and so I think he's
going to come in with a lot of new ideas
he understands I believe that the
impression is that he sort of got stale
in Green Bay whether it's right or
whether it's wrong that's the impression
so I think he's gonna come in there I
think he's gonna blow away David Tepper
in an interview but just remember one
thing
Tepper really wanted Ron Rivera to to
embracing analytics more than he did so
I think he's gonna be asking everybody
when he interviews him how willing are
you to accept new ideas and to you know
hire an analytic staff it's good picked
by you he was on my list as well I mean
Mike McCarthy deserves to be a head
coach I mean come on he's a Super Bowl
winning head coach my issue with him was
offensive creativity I just wish he
brings more ideas to the table
that would be the only question I have
about him but as far as you know running
the ship and doing the things properly
as far as building a team and doing all
that stuff toughness he is he's
phenomenal that way all right I'm gonna
go with a guy and bought another guy in
Baltimore I'm going with Don wink
Martindale I'm going with wink
Martindale I mean you know again you
know the defense in Baltimore is every
bit as impressive as the offense you
know their ability to do crazy things
game plan wise week in week out you talk
about the analytics thing you know I
don't I'm Baltimore's very into
analytics and they're on the cutting
edge of some of the things they're doing
down there so that to me again it's
another defensive guys with defensive
guys know how to manage games they know
how to run the ball and I am into the
era of you can't just play defense and
go this is what we do when we're gonna
be sound it's just changed the world
it's changed quarterbacks are two good
offenses are too creative the receivers
are too good running backs can catch the
ball if you're not willing to bend your
defensive rules on a week-to-week basis
and come up with different stuff to stop
a different offense and then how they
attack you then you know I you're you're
doing a yourself a bad wound oh I want
to say a disfavor to your team and I
think Don's is service Thank You
disservice wink Martindale would be up
there for me hey you know I think the
Andy Reid assistants have kind of the
shine has gone off a little bit this
year with Matt naggy and Doug Peterson
the Eagles struggling I still think Eric
be enemy deserves consideration he got
none
last year for reasons that are neither
obvious nor apparent and I think that he
should get consideration and you can
bring that mindset of the Andy Reid
offensive system if you're looking for
an offensive coach I think it makes a
ton of sense I would just want to know
what his plan is on defense because Andy
Reid's defences haven't been very good
in Kansas City but I would I would
seriously consider Eric be enemy as my
second pick maybe should make Luke
Kuechly player coach my third guy would
be Kevin Stefanski of the Minnesota
Vikings you know he came close to
getting the Cleveland job last year
there are people in the Cleveland front
office who absolutely loved Kevin
Stefanski I think he's ready I think he
embraces analytics and I think he can
show David Tepper I had a quarterback
who was struggling and he's played
significantly better in all moments in
2019 and Kirk Cousins so I think he
would give him the requisite faith that
he could either develop Cam Newton into
into the kind of offense he wanted to
play or he could go get another
quarterback and develop him yeah this is
a tough one here there's a lot of names
to pick from I'm not sure where I want
to go here because Dennis Allen Dan
Campbell down there in New Orleans or
entry here he goes get a list ten guys
to these guys I'm gonna go one with just
the young offensive mind okay I'm gonna
do I'm gonna fall into the trap one time
and I'm gonna give Kellen Moore some
props all right I mean hey listen I
questioned whether Kliff Kingsbury had
work I questioned whether Matt Lafleur
would work you know and and and you know
they're proving that they're certainly
worthy of the job Kellen Moore he's done
a really good job with that Dallas
Cowboys offense you know do they manage
the games the proper way all the time
I'm not sure they do but he certainly
added a lot of creativity the offense
which has been one of my big complaints
about what they do there you know they
are the number one offense in football
or they're the number two offense just
slightly behind the Baltimore Ravens
right now know they're number one I was
right so I like some of the ideas he's
brought to the table and you know it's
it's the era of the young offensive mind
and I think he could kind of fit that
mold he looks like he walked
middle school coach you're gonna coach a
team that is in the tobacco capital
world it would be a good idea to be old
enough to smoke so I think he's I think
that's a stretch for Kellan or okay I'm
gonna go to the other extreme I'm gonna
go and and I this one's nuts but what
the hell you guys screwed me and gave me
the third pick we're down to selection
number nine David Tepper Pittsburgh guy
partial owner of the Steelers he's been
out there for over a decade I know he
ain't coming back but why not swing for
the fences and go after Bill Cowher baby
bring him back he was linked to the
Panthers 10 11 12 years ago go after
Bill Cowher they got Jon Gruden after
almost 10 years to come out of whatever
he was retired from coaching but in
broadcasting cowers been in the same gig
bring him back get into Carolina
wouldn't that be a great story I love a
great story Bill Cowher returning after
12 years would be awesome you guys
wouldn't be an awesome story the the
question is you know does he want to do
it I have not heard one one scintilla of
evidence that suggests that Bill Cowher
either a misses coaching or B really
wants to be a coach so unless you're
you've got the ethos of Dick Vermeil and
you would walk from Philadelphia to
Charlotte for that job I mean I think I
think Bill Cowher really likes is his
New York New Jersey life right now I
just I can't see it but who knows
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports